I'm guessing you probably figured out that gamma was still 1.25, since β was still 0.6.
But you may have tried to divide by gamma instead of multiply, 8 seconds by 1.25
because the correct answer really is 10.
Now, you may be asking--I thought when 8 seconds corresponded to 10 down here
does not mean fewer seconds corresponds to more seconds?
How could it be the case that when I'm in this spaceship my friends waving every 8 seconds
10 seconds elapsed on my clock.
It's not a problem with the clocks. This is an inherit part of special relativity.
It's something you will learn much more about as you take more courses.
Unfortunately, today is just a teaser.
If you want to read more, I suggest you look at the twin paradox and other links below this video.